this entire talk has
seriously been inspired by a
conversation between two professional
adults
where one person said we came up with
some rules that automated bottleneck
and on the other side of the room there
was someone saying but that's not ai
it's not even data science
and kind of what i want to talk about is
that
back in the good old days we had these
systems that would do data science
but the way they worked is fundamentally
different than what we do nowadays
before it was kind of normal that you
said well we've got some data
and we want to automate this decision
making process so what we then do is we
get a domain expert in
and maybe with some probability rules
but effectively we get the domain expert
to
come up with some rules such that we can
automate this
decision making labeling like we can
generate labels this way we can automate
decisions
that's how that used to work nowadays
it's a lot more fashionable to not
you know do the effort of actually
understanding the data and sort of
coming up with domain rules
instead nowadays what we do is we just
apply a lot of math
and geometric tricks to separate data
points
with this thing called machine learning
we just put it in a big bowl
and eventually rules will come out now
there's merit to this idea because it's
automatable and you know
we also tend to get high accuracy scores
but i've started wondering for a while
now
that in this transition from these
rule-based systems down to this more
machine-learning way of thinking
that maybe we should admit that we
didn't get better at solving all of the
problems out there
in fact maybe this machine learning way
of thinking is introducing new kinds of
problems
and maybe what we should do is figure
out a better way to combine the two
that we can say well we've got these
rule-based systems that the machine
learning can use
and we've got this machine learning that
the rule-based systems can use
i my hypothesis is is that if we
approach
problems this way odds are that we have
better solutions
so the way i want to talk about this is
first i want to talk about some lessons
i've learned while making content for
the spacey project on youtube
then i would like to also discuss some
lessons i've learned in the past have
here
while working for my new employer raza
and then i want to maybe
take those lessons and see if we can
apply them to psychic learn
which will then conclude by by saying
well i've made this new package and i
think it's going to help solve some
problems
especially in this particular space
so let's talk about a very specific
problem that you see
quite commonly in natural language
processing
there's this problem called ner which
stands for named entity recognition and
what it basically boils down to is that
when presented with a bit of text
you might want to be able to detect
specific entities from it
you can think of like phone numbers for
example but you can also think of well
i have these people references that i
would like to retrieve
maybe there's a reference to an
organization or to a city or to money
but we would like to have an algorithm
that can detect very specific entities
for us
in an automated way and what i've been
doing in the last year kind of as a
hobby project
the creative space he reached out to me
and asked me if i was willing to help
them
make some good content on youtube and
i've been solving a variant of this
problem
i wasn't interested in detecting people
though what i thought was interesting
is to go out there and get me a data set
about programming languages
because i figured it would be
interesting to see if i can make an
algorithm that can automatically detect
programming languages or programming
tools from a text
because i think there's some interesting
applications that you can do with that
if you can do that properly
the thing though is it's actually quite
a hard problem
it's by no means obvious i mean sure
it's pretty easy to detect like
the the string of python i suppose right
i mean that's relatively easy just reg
exit and you're done
but the problem is you can't always do
that because you got this programming
language called go
and the thing with go is it is a really
common
like word in the english language but
the way it's most often used is not in
reference to a programming language
in fact go is the most common verb in
the english language
so even if you were to throw embeddings
at it odds are you're not going to be
hitting the thing you're interested in
so you got something maybe more clever
and machine learning algorithms actually
have a hard time doing this so i had to
do something else pragmatic
so what i'll do now is i'll just show
you the short version of the trick that
got me there but then i'll talk about
the larger issue when i'm done talking
about syntax
but what i kind of want to do just real
quick is just show you how this amazing
feature in spacey works and how it's
helped me solve this problem
here's a jupiter notebook and what i'm
doing here is i'm loading up a natural
language processing model from spacey
the small english model that's trained
on the web corpus to be specific
in short what spacey does is you can
take that model object
give it a bit of text and what comes out
is a document that contains tokens
and in this particular case for the
english language it's just a white space
pardon tokenizer but one of the things
that spacey will do for me
is it will add information to all of
these separate tokens there's a machine
learning model that's quite general that
does that
in particular what you're going to get
is this token
what's the part of speech for it so you
can imagine well is it a noun or is it a
verb
verifoart by vuklik namwort in dutch um
and the thing is that's kind of nice is
given such a general model for the
grammar
it's relatively easy to come up with a
rule-based system for the go programming
language
and in spacey what you would do is you
would say well
i've got this matcher object
and the matcher basically accepts a
pattern definition
which in this case would be well if the
text is lowercase go
and the part of speech of that token is
not a verb
okay then i can match and say that that
is indeed the go programming language
what i can also do is i can add a second
pattern saying if it's golang as text
and it's probably also about the go
programming language
and suddenly when you just come up with
this fairly simple rule based system
it just kind of works here we see that
i program and go go is detected
correctly
i go and write code well go is a verb
here so it's not detecting that as a
programming language
how to make web requests and go it kind
of works
now of course i'm using something
machine learning under the hood to make
this rule-based system
but i hope that you would agree that
this is relatively robust and
i can stand by my own domain knowledge
that this will probably work for a lot
of cases
and just to give like a slightly better
impression of what else you can do with
these rules
what you can also do is you can generate
these rules automatically
because in the end the definition is
just a list with a python dictionary
inside of it
what you can also do is write a function
such that you can also capture the
version
of a programming language
if you're doing natural language
processing and you're interested in
fetching programming languages
i hope that you would agree that python
2.7 is different than python 3.6
would be kind of a bummer if we fetched
python but not the version number
but the nice thing about this rule-based
system is that i don't have to do this
endless labeling or
collecting tons of data i can just kind
of come up with a rule
and that'll probably go ahead and work
so i hope if nothing else that you would
agree that this rule-based system
it's not even really machine learning
end-to-end anything but it is really
pragmatic it is super helpful
this however was only the introduction
the real lesson comes now
because you have to imagine i now have
this matcher object
and the match object is just quite
pragmatic i can just
come up with some domain knowledge apply
that to some csv files
i can look at some rows and i can look
at the csv file for a bit maybe add some
more matcher rules
um but by doing this what i got
effectively was this data set that i
could go ahead to label
what i then did is i took that label
data set
and then i went ahead to train this
actual machine learning model
spacey comes with some deep learning
models for you to use as well so what i
did effectively was
first make this match a ruler and then
get this data set such that i can make a
machine learning model
and that i can kind of compare both
approaches i also hope just here you
would agree that's useful
because we would expect this machine
learning model to perform much better
than
the basic rules so to say if the basic
rules work better we should not consider
this guy
so spacey makes this quite easy from the
command line you can
basically save your rule based system as
well as your machine learning model and
you can do some comparisons
and one thing that stuck out to me was
that you know
if you look at the f1 score this is the
machine learning model
this is the the other one the rule-based
one and you know this is just way higher
and the reason why it's way higher is
because the precision is way better on
the machine learning side
now a bit bit of a hint at these moments
you shouldn't go ahead and say ah
the machine learning model is there for
better because there's something really
weird happening here and i'm wondering
if you can see it
in the interest of time i'll just tell
you but
isn't it kind of weird that the recall
for the machine learning model
is lower than the recall for the
rule-based system
i might argue that the rule-based system
that's bounded right um
the machine learning model can sort of
hopefully look outside of the bounds
that i as a human have declared
and may be generalized by covering more
ground but that's not at all what's
happening here
apparently the precision is higher not
the recall
so then i'm wondering is this machine
learning model even generalizing
so at moments like this i like to not go
for the better model at moments like
this i like to understand what the
difference is
so the way i went about that is by
basically saying well let's not take the
qualitative route let's maybe do this a
bit more
uh qualitative so let's not go for
quantity let's go for quality that one
sorry
and here's some examples that i found in
instances where they both
failed effectively a lot of that was
contributing to the tokenizer
when you have something like c sharp and
you have c sharp version seven
or c sharp immediately a comma and then
like a list of programming languages
okay it's good to understand that the
tokenizer that's trained on normal
english languages
is gonna have a bit of trouble here um
it's still
it's not gonna help me but it is good to
understand a failure scenario for the
system
instances where both models tended to
work equally we're moments where we're
talking about java
and python and golang and and javascript
those were interested it just got all of
them
but there were moments where there was
disagreement between both models and
that's where the interesting thing
started happening
in particular the main thing i was
surprised by was that the machine
learning model wasn't unable to capture
common lisp
this surprised me because common lisp is
pretty well defined you can just get it
by string matching
but then after investigating i found out
that common lisp doesn't exist
in the training data at all the reason
why common list was detected by the rule
based system
was because i was able to write down
with my domain knowledge that this
programming language actually exists
and this is a nice reminder a rule-based
system can actually make a
proper classification even if there's no
data that's the art of it that's what a
rule based system can do
if there's no examples of something that
you're interested if there's no examples
of the thing that you're interested in
machine learning is not going to help
you but it's weird because you sometimes
are able to define what you're
interested in
even if you don't have data for it so
this was a clear win for the rule based
system but there was something else
happening as well
the fact that it couldn't detect go
indicated a more subtle problem
and here's the issue java python
and javascript those are all pretty easy
languages to detect
but they're also by far the most
frequent languages out there
if i'm not mistaken i think java python
and javascript are the most popular ones
out there
so it's no surprise that the stack
overflow data set therefore has lots of
examples of those
and maybe not as many for go
and if i then start thinking about oh
yeah but the precision was way higher
and the recall was lower
then you can start wondering well that
data set that i'm judging this system on
if it only has these easy examples
then i'm judging my grid search maybe on
the wrong thing and there's evidence of
that happening now
so i'm super happy i didn't do grid
search here
but then now you get to think about how
to actually solve this problem
and i i really like the system that we
ended up with
back to the drawing board what i ended
up doing is i said well let's have a
minimum
oops let's have a minimum amount of
examples
uh per programming language so you know
just to make sure that
also the more obscure languages we have
at least 50 examples of each
in the training data just start with and
it includes some of the languages that
are
harder to detect next what i did
is i said well let's just have a look at
when both of these models disagree
now let's also say that the instances
where both of those disagree
that's the moment when i'm going to
start labeling again i'm not just going
to grab randomly from the csv file
because
odds are i'm just going to get the
popular languages and i want to have a
general model
but the cool thing is if i work fire
this flow
every time i do an iteration harder
instances get into this labeled data set
the machine learning model will get
better but also the matcher
because i'm labeling manually i can also
get inspired
to add a new rule to the matcher so
every time i'm doing this
the matcher gets better the machine
learning model gets better which also
means that these
moments where i disagree become more
interesting
and i think this is a really nice way to
think about solving a problem it's
also about understanding your problem a
bit better and
to be honest you could not have gotten
here without
this rule-based system it actually
helped me design
all of this
and in the aftermath um one thing
i was happy with is yes the scores
after became a lot worse than what i had
before
but i didn't care because the data set
that i'm applying this on
is one that's more reliable in
particular the main thing that i really
loved seeing
was the fact that the recall actually
increased
so the precision stayed the same between
both models but now at least i had
evidence that the machine learning model
was generalizing beyond the rules that i
had
another thing that i really like is i
have a rule-based system as well as a
machine learning one
they both work on fundamentally
different ways so
whenever they agree i have a really
strong signal that is probably a
programming language
so just a few observations we've seen
that a rule based system definitely can
save ml
in situations where you don't have a lot
of data the rule-based system made the
statistical system better
the statistical system also made the
rule-based system better
the interaction wasn't just between
systems i the human in the loop also
understood the failure scenarios of both
model a lot better by
doing this and my labeling strategy is
really effective now
but moreover by thinking about rules
this way and checking if they work
i have a fundamentally different way of
approaching a machine learning problem
i'm actually iterating on my data here
as well and not just my model
and that is a fresh perspective if i
compare to what most people do when they
call fit predict
so i hope that this demonstrates some of
the utility of these rule-based systems
but it's not just with spacey that i've
noticed that this is super useful
um i nowadays work for a conversational
company and what we do is
we try to make a system that makes it
easy for you to
generate a very proper and very safe
conversational agent
chatbots and that sort of stuff and one
thing that can happen when you're
you know making such a system is that
you can have a conversation
in which the user
asks the virtual assistant are you a
human
and what we would like the virtual
assistant to do primarily
is to reply by saying nope i'm uh i'm
not a human
we really don't want to have the ethical
concern that our systems are going to
pretend to be humans
and after that we really like them to
recover the conversation that they were
doing already
so at raza when i just started we had
recently made the system
that was really good at recovering so
it's actually quite hard to fool i've
tried it a bunch of times
but we now have a system that can take
this training data and it's really
really good at saying well
okay this is an interruption we now have
to get back to the topic at hand
but if you think about what's more
important what's more important is this
part that
no matter what happens in my
conversation i'm always able to say
i'm not a human that's the ethical thing
that's the part that we actually care
more of
and that's also where maybe there's a
small concern if you think about like
an example of this like the training
data you would have for such a system
one risk that you might have is that all
of these are your human questions
that they're asked at the beginning of
your conversation as opposed at the end
it can be that we have too many examples
in our training data
where we have easy examples so to say
but that in production if someone were
to say at the end of a conversation
are you a human that we might not give
this response which is like
super important so then you can wonder
do we really want to have this decision
being determined by a machine learning
model
or do we maybe just want to add a rule
as an insurance policy
if we detect someone is asking this
question no matter what else is
happening in the conversation
we must always reply that we're not
human
and if you think about it that's also a
rule-based system
and that idea of being able to add this
insurance policy
that's actually a new feature that we've
added in rasa 2.0 it's something that
is going to come out in a couple of
weeks another way of fixing this issue
is not to say well you have to introduce
a rule certainly what you can also do
is you can iterate on data but one thing
that's likely not going to help you
is iterating on the model it's going to
be
kind of dangerous if you really strictly
care about this insurance policy
to trust that the grid search will solve
all of this
and that's kind of what we saw before as
well we kind of want to have systems
that play by the rules we don't just
want to have
optimal grid search we want to have
models that have other
types of properties that we're
interested in and at the moment we might
be overfitting
on grid searches
so i've talked about the text use case
now rules can save the day in data poor
situations
even without data rules are awesome
domain knowledge is great
we have safety mechanisms and we can
apply these rules to subsets of data
that are really well understood
but the main question that you might
have now for yourself
is can we do this on non-text data like
all these results are great but so far
i've only argued for them in the text
domain
and we can ask ourselves well can we
maybe do this for tabular data
as well
and i would say yeah i think we can
let's say that you're world of warcraft
and you have
session logs of every player that's ever
played your video game
and you want to figure out who's going
to churn and who's going to keep on
playing
sure you can make a machine learning
model i think that's a good idea
but before you apply the machine
learning model there's probably also a
rule you can just apply
if you're the kind of person that plays
world of warcraft at midnight during new
year's eve
then you know you're probably a hardcore
gamer you're definitely well invested in
this
do we really need a machine learning
model to tell us that you're probably
not going to churn
or can we maybe design a system where we
say well you know what
we have some sort of a rule that just
says you're a heavy user or you're not
and if you're a heavy user then don't
even bother with a machine learning
algorithm we kind of already know what's
going to happen
only when we have to resort to a machine
learning model that's where we're going
to fall back to it
and there's actually lots of systems
that can be written this way let's say
you're doing fraud
i don't know if you're a tax agency if
you're a child and you have
above median income okay that's a risk
if you're a person with more than 10
bank accounts i don't need a machine
learning model just
you're a risk that that's already a
business rule i can go ahead and apply
only after you've done lots of these
rules maybe then you can say okay and
this is something i'm going to
give to the machine learning model as a
final resort so to say
and you can even think of like proper
safety constraints on the system
if you get a new data point x and that
data point x is considered an outlier as
in
the machine learning model has never
seen anything like it then it shouldn't
have an opinion on it
maybe if we detect an outlier we can
also say ah business rule
you gotta fall back now and if the
certainty isn't high enough for your
machine learning model okay
another good reason to not automate the
prediction
again we're dealing here with the
rule-based system and i hope that you
would agree that you don't have to be in
a text domain
to take these rules kind of serious
there's actually something cool you can
do
if you can join your machine learning
approach with these rules
then the question is though like i hope
i've convinced you that at least in your
mind you can agree
that there has to be some interaction
here there's benefits to be had
it's not just benchmarking this system
against machine learning interaction
here will be cool
so now the only question you might have
is well what can we do to make this as
easy as possible
to sort of use your human knowledge and
rules in psychic learn
and for that i am announcing now that i
have made this new package called
human learn and as a name might imply
you can kind of guess what it does
what i'm going to do now is just give
you a simple overview of like two of the
main features
it's my mom texting me um
so here we go i'm in a notebook and
let's say i've got this data set called
load
titanic i have to predict whether or not
you survive the titanic disaster
and i'm able to do that based on all of
this information
if i can come up with a simple rule then
one thing i can imagine is if you paid
more for a ticket you're probably closer
to a lifeboat
i can definitely imagine that if you
were a first class paid a lot
that you're more on the upper deck and
probably not on the lower deck
so just as a benchmark how about i just
say look just take this column the fare
and if you're and let's just pick a
threshold and if you're over the
threshold then you probably survived and
if you're under the threshold you
probably didn't
it's a simple machine learning model but
if only as a benchmark i hope you would
agree
it's not the worst idea
and what's the easiest way to write such
a rule-based system in python
well probably a function what you're
probably going to do
is you're going to have a function that
takes a data frame as input maybe it has
a threshold over here
and what you want to do then is you want
to maybe say something like hey
if we're over a certain threshold
predict one otherwise predict zero and
do that for all the rows
the only issue is is that this function
is not a psychic learn compatible
classifier
so the first thing that this library
does is it just makes it easy to turn
these functions
into psychic learn compatible
classifiers if you define it this way
you have your argument here that you
also define here then what this
class will do is it will make sure that
you have a function that you can grid
search over
which in turn means you can use it for
benchmarking
in particular what you're going to see
here below is the code that is needed to
do that
but the more important and i think more
interesting thing is that you can look
at your grid search results and then see
that yeah when you
tweak your threshold parameter here then
you can see that just this one basic
rule
you know it kind of already is able to
achieve
60 ish accuracy and uh you know
80 precision and just by making
this rule-based system there's also this
notion that you're going to understand
your data just a bit better
and it's not just this moment where you
can make a classifier to make like
something that's accurate
what you can also do is make systems
like this you can also make systems that
take pre-existing machine learning tools
and turn those into a rule based system
as well
there's a bit of an example that i'll
quickly just show you here the most
important thing to take away from this
is that we have an outlier
and a classifier model and effectively
what's happening inside of this function
is we're saying this np where clause a
couple of times where
if this predicate holds then we are
going to override
the prediction that we start with so if
nothing happens we just go for the
classification that we had
but if where the probability is not high
enough then we have this fallback
scenario
otherwise we have another fallback
scenario and lo and behold you now have
a system that can do the won't predict
thing
just by using tools that are available
already
so we have these function tools they are
available as a classifier or aggressor
as well as an outlier detector
but there's one other thing that i think
is going to be a more interesting
direction for this project
because maybe we can not only think of
how do we make
rule-based systems easier but also how
can i make it easier to come up with
rule-based systems in the first place
and that's and the best way to summarize
that actually is just to look at this
chart um this is like the iris data set
this is just some sort of
chart that you can look at and i think
the reason why
a lot of us resort to machine learning
probably has to do with the fact that
it's kind of hard to automatically you
know
come up with code that can sort of draw
a shape around a data set if you will
it'd be kind of nice if instead of you
know
it'd be nice if we can just put an if
statement down here and we'd have to
shape
but unfortunately code is not the right
way to get there
but one thing that we can do basically
maybe
draw a classifier
to be honest the way that this works um
we've got these point in poly algorithms
right
so i can make a drawing of polygons of
interest
and i can say well some of these
polygons have a name attached that
coincidentally is attached to the
name of a class and with these drawn
polygons i can also come up with nice
little rules
like the obvious rule could be well if a
data point uh falls into a polygon
that's an excellent reason to say ah
probably belongs to a class
another thing that i can do is i can
maybe not just make one of these
drawings i can probably make many
and then i can average between the
polygons that you fall into
thing that i can kind of do is i can say
well if you don't fall in any polygons
you're probably an outlier
but i think the more important thing
that's interesting about this is that by
making models this way
not only do you have maybe a good
benchmark for a model but you're also
doing your exploratory
analysis at the same time i kind of
started getting a little bit tired of
all of these people just calling
fit predict xy and then calling it a day
if you look at kaggle there's a lot of
that stuff happening it actually kind of
gets scary we shouldn't have that much
faith in our machine learning systems
instead i think it's going to be a lot
nicer to just draw models like this
see it as a benchmark and if this model
already kind of works
that's kind of nice because it also
means that we can maybe make these
drawings for situations where labels are
not available
we can also make these drawings for
those situations and we can also get
domain knowledge in
again if only as a benchmark
a final thing to maybe mention just
because i think it's a really cool
feature
uh right let's just also show that we
can turn that drawing we just made into
a classifier by the way
um so we get the three classes based on
the drawings that we just made
but another thing i think is just kind
of nice to just sort of show you
is that we can also give this chart not
the labels but just
features that we're interested in so
let's say that i'm just kind of
interested in
you know this subset of the data these
charts also allow you to do is pass that
information onto pandas
so if you're interested in a subset for
research you can also use this tool just
for interactive exploration as well
so that was a brief demo
um you might have a question so one
question could be should i use it well
you're definitely free to
it's pip installable documentation's
ready and there's also lots of tutorials
you might ask yourself should i put in
production i mean it's a month old
maybe not uh open source works when
folks contribute
uh when people contribute to find all
the edge cases and currently the edge
cases are kind of unknown
definitely feel free to collaborate but
um don't put it in production just yet
uh is it perfect nope totally not uh
there's actually an extra risk of data
leakage definitely watch out for that
it's super dangerous
and you also need to think about what
you're doing because you can also add
bad rules
and then you might ask well vincent why
did you make this well i
i'm getting tired i'm looking at these
machine learning models that don't play
by the rules and i think that that's
actually a nice analogy of how we should
think about our systems
we need these systems to play by the
rules data professionals need to iterate
on data
and also keep thinking and all this
stuff needs to be easier so this is my
sort of answer to how maybe we should do
this
then you might ask vincent what's your
best feature in this entire package
which is why i asked people like hey
shall i end with a poem
um kuhn i will not be doing it in brahms
unfortunately because i think the
minority of the people watching
understand that um but the best feature
of the entire package is what you can do
is from you learn you can call import
this
and it shows you all the lessons that
i've learned while making this package
in rhyme why worry about the state of
the art
maybe it's time that we all admit that
one size fits all suit
is not bespoke and usually does not fit
computers can flow a lot of tensors but
they never really learn
natural intelligence is still a good
idea and natural stupidity is a valid
concern
there are many ways to solve a problem
but don't let fancy tools get to your
head
why would you choose a predefined
solution if you can create a custom one
instead thanks everyone for listening
if you're interested i will be making
more spacey content keep an eye on
twitter i will definitely have like a
big announcement about that one of these
days
if you're interested in this human
learning thing i've added a free course
on calm code io
it has like a full tutorial so you can
totally go around and check that
if you're interested in nlp though also
just reach out to me i'm doing a bunch
of open source work in nlp space
and there's also a youtube channel where
i explain algorithms if that's of
interest
thanks for listening thank you vincent
actually we have quite some interesting
uh questions so
wait i want to answer one question first
because the previous speaker i was
talking about missing data right
okay let's let's do that thing first
another way of dealing with missing data
by the way if you make a model that's
like this drawing
notice that if a data point is missing
on these two columns right
but it's not missing on these two you
can still say oh but it falls in this
polygon so i can still make a prediction
just saying it's another way of thinking
about making uh dealing with missing
data you can also
ignore it anyway questions i guess yes
um a question from jorn
why would embeddings not be suitable
wouldn't they be able to encode the
context in which the programming
language tokens
appear in sentences about the beginning
of your talk
well if you're going to end up training
your own maybe but certainly not the
predator
certainly not the pre-trained ones right
that's the main thing the pre-trained
ones that are trained on wikipedia
probably will overfit on the general
case and not directly
applicable to what i'm using that's the
thing like in general the word go is
really reserved to be a verb like
there's no way around that it's really
the most common uh usage for it
even in a sec overflow data set there's
more uses cases for
go being a verb than it for being a
programming language even in this use
case
so training your own embeddings you can
try but it's not easy
okay then on to the
next question from hectare
business process management and
integration of machine learning system
inside workflow makes good sense but
does this mean we take data away from a
machine learning model
during training phase or should we train
with full data but only serve the model
for the ones that fall out of the
business domain rules
that's a lot of business terms um so
in this particular case if you're going
to do the drawing approach and even if
you do the function classifier approach
there's not really fitting anymore is it
you're just saying well i as a human
declared these are the rules to follow
and those are the rules you should just
take into consideration
um like um
i forgot about the first part of the
question now sorry
basically it's um
should we train the machine learning
model on the complete data set or only
on the
data that has been filtered by the
business rules oh
um uh i don't have a good answer for
that in general
just try it out on your own data that's
that's i think the best way to
to verify for sure um again the
the risk here is that you can also come
up with rules that make no sense and are
actually bad right so that's the
new hypothesis you have to concern
yourself with
okay cool and then a question from juan
which is quite interesting i think so
the method the iterative method that you
propose would you consider it to be some
kind of active learning
that you apply i mean that's that's one
way of thinking i mean
i'm not super aware of the exact
definition of active learning
um i'm just copying what the spacey
people call it which i
i think enos was the first one to coin
uh iterate on your data instead
and the reason why i sympathize with it
is also that you have to be careful
because
a lot of these labeled data sets can't
really be trusted um
so that's more the concern that i have
i've more of the concern that there
might be a
labeling issue i suppose than that i'm
trying to
not label as much i think active
learning as a field is a little bit more
concerned with well
labeling is expensive how can we
minimize the costs whereas my concern is
a little bit more
well do i even trust the data to begin
with yeah
i think so basically what you're saying
is that if you take
out of the box active learning approach
probably it's not really covering it
because then you're still using a model
to see
where you're inaccurate while your
business rules actually have a more
human training approach right the the
main reason why i think this approach
works is because the rule-based systems
indeed
work on a very different method than the
machine learning one
with active learning as you just said i
do think it's a valid concern
but if there's bias in your data set in
the first place that active learning is
maybe gonna keep it
so you're basically using the human
intelligence to find your edge cases
that you're missing if you just look at
your accuracy right
yeah and i think natural intelligence is
still a pretty good idea
i mean artificial intelligence can work
but human intelligence
sounds good so
then there's another question about um
the snorkel project uh you're familiar
with the project
a little bit um i've talked to people
who use it so i know people who use it
in fraud situations and
one story i heard is that someone's
actually quite happy with it
i don't know it well enough to
understand the magic that it does under
the hood i believe it
basically says well you got a couple of
rules that we don't fully trust
and then we combine them in a magic way
and then it's better it's just that i
don't understand what the magic way
exactly entails in order for me to give
confidence in it
it really sounds like magic right yeah
so
so there's a little bit of a black box
thing to it also uh
yeah and again um i wouldn't want to
suggest that rule-based systems are the
end-all of everything like it's
it's it's more of a tool that you can
use and i think it started getting a bad
reputation even though i keep seeing it
does wonders
um so that's why i figured maybe just
talking about it
um let's see we have actually a lot of
questions
um yeah so i think we're running late
already a little bit so let's move the
questions
to uh to discord and we can continue the
discussion there
meanwhile a little bit of an
announcement we have
one talk that is unfortunately cancelled
so that's the talk about
the second one after the break
from uh three yeah so if some last
minute schedule
changes so just a heads up that this
talk
unfortunately will be cancelled so it's
the one about the reinforcement learning
uh in greenhouses
so vincent thank you very much for your
talk uh and
uh yeah let's continue the discussion on
this card
i will i will definitely respond to
anyone anytime
thanks yes i know thank you vincent
thanks